[Music]
in case you've been hiding under a rock
or if you just don't have Twitter bless
your heart Kanye West made his return to
the platform and proceeded to crack the
internet with seven dirty words which
would have put even George Carlin to
shame last Saturday Kanye tweeted I love
the way Candace Owens thinks if you
don't know Candace Owens she's a black
conservative woman who originally went
under the YouTube moniker red pill black
Candace caught fire online around the
summer of 2017 and my interview with her
in which we discussed her evolution from
a lefty to a conservative is one of the
moments that really put her on the map
it was the first time that she had been
able to explain herself in her own words
in a long-form conversational setting I
don't want to rehash the whole thing
right now but Candace is no stranger to
controversy and you may remember that
infamous debate that I had with Candace
and Blair white late last year the whole
thing was a debacle I make no bones
about it but hashtag save Dave trended
on Twitter so Who am I to complain 2018
has already been a huge year for Candace
as she was hired as communications
director for Turning Point USA the
largest conservative college group in
America since then she's been touring
the country with Charlie Kirk talking to
young people particularly young black
people as why they should embrace the
victor mentality rather than the victim
mentality this is included directly
attacking the black lives matter
movement as well as democratic policies
which Candice argues has decimated the
black family and the black community
just last week Candice Charlie and I
spoke at Berkeley to a wild crowd I'm
proud to say that we had agreements and
we had disagreements and even though our
styles are different no doubt Candis
certainly goes for the jugular more than
I do I always enjoyed doing events with
her and seeing her evolve politically
something I know a bit about myself
she's learning as she goes and as she
said to me in our interview if I had
swallowed the red pill then she had
snorted it beyond any of the politics
though Candice is a friend and our
differences don't define us they
actually bring us together all right
back to Kanye for a second beyond the
headlines I don't know what ton about
him although I'm obviously aware enough
to recognize what a transcendent
cultural figure he is
not only is he hugely successful in the
music world he has a hugely successful
fashion line and is married to Kim
Kardashian who has her own Empire you
may not like the guy for whatever reason
but make no mistake he is an absolute
mogul I may not like or even respect the
influence that celebrities have over
culture these days but Kanye is truly
someone who can move people's minds with
what he raps or with what he tweets this
is exactly what happened with these
seven words immediately after Kanye's
tweet in support of Candace the internet
went ablaze Twitter moments lead story
was about Kanye support for far-right
Candace Owens Candice was called anti
gay and racist something I'm still
confused about as she's had dinner here
with me and my husband at our home where
her anti gayness never seemed to leak
out as for Asus there's nothing like a
white lefty telling a black person who
doesn't think as they demand that they
do that the black person is the actual
racist against their own race irony is
truly dead folks on Monday this week
Kanye refused to back down despite
hysterics from the media he tweeted out
a bunch of videos by another former
Rubin report guest best-selling author
and Dilbert creator Scott Adams in
essence these videos were Scott talking
about what a freethinker Kanye is that's
it next thing you know the usual
suspects like BuzzFeed mediate The Daily
Beast and others were labeling Scott
Adams as far-right we've seen the script
a million times before with anyone who
dare challenge leftist orthodoxy be it
Candice Scott Colin Moriarty Jordan
Peterson or even little ol me when
mainstream media has moved so far left
that this wide collection of people are
all smeared with the same charges of
far-right racism you know that the
Overton Window hasn't just shifted it's
shattered the authors of these pieces
aren't journalists they're activists or
as Candace says they aren't journalists
their hit men to recap we have a new
player in Candace who is fearlessly
saying how she believes that the
Democrats have used the black community
for decades and that the victimhood
mentality of the left is the root of
this problem this by the way is similar
to what plenty of other conservatives
have been saying for years and yes this
includes even black
conservatives like my former guests
Larry elder and Thomas soul the voices
of black conservatives and others
espousing similar ideas has been largely
ignored by the mainstream media however
and that is exactly why everyone is
freaking out about Kanye's tweets he
just gave oxygen to a set of ideas that
the Democrats and the mainstream media
don't want you to hear and since they've
controlled the narrative for so long
they've relied on the usual smears of
racism homophobia and bigotry instead of
strengthening their own ideas your ideas
get fat and lazy when you don't have to
work them out because you've owned the
narrative for so long this is where the
modern left finds itself right now if
Candace's views are far-right then that
means that about 40% of America if not
more falls into that category I do want
to address a different lurking danger
here however I know Candis and I believe
her to be forthright and passionate as
she figures this all out I obviously
don't know Kanye nor any of his
political beliefs so we have an
interesting match here where Candis is
now the rocket and Kanye is the jet fuel
if Candis doesn't do the intellectual
work to really figure out what she
believes and why she believes it all the
while being under the insane microscope
of the media that's gonna be praying for
her to fail well then the rocket will be
faulty and this experiment will blow up
what if Kanye says something absolutely
crazy tomorrow which is not only
possible it's probable or something
that's counter to everything else that
Candice believes he's been known to stir
the pot and I can only assume that
something like that will happen either
intentionally or by mistake
does her rocket ship run out of fuel in
mid-flight where does that leave this
incredible momentum over the past year
when I've talked to people like Eric and
brett weinstein jordan peterson ben
shapiro larry elder Thomas Saul and many
others what I'm most impressed by is how
complete their outlook on politics and
more broadly on life is they don't jump
from conclusion to conclusion depending
on the political climate they try to
really understand what they
fundamentally think so as new issues
arise their responses are complete
rather than conflicted this is something
I've really tried to incorporate into my
thinking and something that I know many
of you are trying to do as well
this
we'll also be Candace's challenge now
and I think she's up to it but only she
can decide that for herself it blows my
mind that every conversation we have in
this room seems to become more and more
relevant as time goes by for all I know
we'll have Kanye in that guest seat soon
enough whether he is just rocket fuel to
boost ideas or is he the rocket ship
that will get us to the solutions
remains to be seen but make no mistake
the issues around free speech political
correctness and the uncomfortable truths
that might be the answers to those
questions have just been levelled up are
the players ready for the next level
we'll soon find out
[Music]
you